here's something that everyone at the
scp foundation knows portals to another
world located in indiana are incredibly
bad news the best example being scp-2935
the limestone cavern in indiana that
leads to a dimension where all life has
ended and death reigns supreme so
considering the importance of keeping
things like this under control we've
decided to fire up the anomatron 6000
and simulate sending one of the
foundation's most reliable senior
researchers dr charles ogden gears to
investigate another dimensional anomaly
this time in a little town called
hawkins indiana can dr gears in his
younger years hold his own against the
demogorgon demma demidogs the mind flare
and even vechna himself let's fire up
the machine and find out it was november
of 1983 and dr gears awoke to a call on
his home phone ordinarily he liked to
start his day with a cold shower and a
cup of plain black coffee but on this
particular very early morning he was
yanked out of a lovely dreamless sleep
by the sound of his superior at the scp
foundation gears there's something
strange going on in this town in indiana
we're putting together a task force and
you're going to lead it what's been
going on we don't know much yet but
there have been reports of strange
noises unusual activity and the local
kids gone missing that was all dr gears
needed to hear all right we'll start
packing he placed the phone back in the
receiver brewed himself that cup of
coffee hopped in the shower and filled a
suitcase with all of his usual
necessities flannel pajamas five white
lab coats plain slacks and shirts and
one pair of sensible shoes he dressed in
an identical outfit to the ones lining
the inside of his slate gray suitcase
combed his hair and straightened his tie
and that was that he was ready for
whatever awaited him on this new mission
when the official scp foundation issued
transportation came to pick him up one
of the task force members handed him a
dossier and a thermos filled with more
coffee enough to sustain him for the
drive so
dr gears flipped open the file taking a
look inside where are we headed don't
know too much about it sir the man
shrugged some little podunk place called
hawkins dr gears spent the drive to
hawkins indiana looking over the few
details the foundation knew so far their
interest had been peaked when a young
boy will byers disappeared mysteriously
on a bike ride home from a friend's
house in addition to the missing
person's report townspeople had called
the authorities to complain about
strange noises and there were rumors of
a secret research project being
conducted by the us government in the
area all of these factors combined to
make hawkins a potential hotbed for
anomalous activity and a place of
significant interest
to the scp foundation dr gears would be
tasked with setting up a temporary
foundation site in town disguised as the
headquarters of a new landscaping
business and leading a group of
researchers in the investigation of the
buyer's disappearance as well as
cataloging other potential anomalies
present in the town they were to remain
there indefinitely and to ensure their
work would not be compromised they were
given strict instructions not to draw
any unnecessary attention to themselves
from civilians or operatives from any
government organizations with an
established presence in the town as dr
gears and his team rolled into the town
he was struck by how completely
absolutely ordinary it was they passed
the town hall the library a general
store a movie theater one sleepy little
pub packed with a few regulars a hunting
and camping supply store a few
diversions for the kids and young at
heart like the arcade schools all
hallmarks of classic american small town
normalcy as they drove out into the
forest around the town however away from
the friendly veneer of suburbia dr gears
spotted something unusual something he
made a note of the second he caught a
glimpse of it there was a large official
looking building surrounded by barbed
wire and armed military guards what's
that there he asked one of his
assistants uh hawkins national
laboratory she replied says here they're
under the jurisdiction of the department
of energy
hmm was all he said he would make sure
to send someone out to investigate once
they were all settled properly after
several years at the foundation he had
something of a sixth sense for detecting
things that didn't seem to belong
this place was not what it claimed to be
by nightfall dr gears and his team of
six officers had settled into their
foundation-provided housing located
across the street from their front
business
privately dr gears hoped that the people
of hawkins weren't especially interested
in landscaping he didn't know a damn
thing about hedges or whatever else that
job entailed while the scp foundation
maintained a steady quiet presence in
hawkins the anomalous activity only
escalated there were reports of a
monster a giant horrible thing with a
humanoid build and a face like an open
flower filled with teeth dr gears and
four members of the team attempted to
track down one of these creatures hoping
to bring it into custody and study it up
close and outside of the home of the
missing boy they finally came face to
face with the thing the predatory
creature was tall and thin with
elongated limbs ending in sharp claws it
reminded dr gears a bit of an anomaly he
had seen in passing though he had never
seen that thing's face this beast
however gave him an up close and
personal look at first glance its head
looked like the closed bud of a flower
with no discernible features however as
it prepared to attack letting out an
unearthly screech fleshy powers unfurled
revealing rows of razor-sharp teeth and
a gaping maw of a mouth the officers
opened fire immediately but their
bullets did little to deter the
advancing creature they only seemed to
make it angry before they could
apprehend the creature or more likely
find themselves pulled into its wide
open mouth they were interrupted by a
group of surprisingly enterprising
children throwing it away seeming to
trap it two teenage boys and a girl
managed to light the beast on fire and
send it retreating back to wherever it
came from dr gears and his men stayed
out of sight as one of them remarked i
guess the children really are our future
meanwhile the other two officers were
following up on reports of a strange
girl appearing in town as if from
nowhere it was difficult to separate
rumor from reality admits talk of secret
government mind experiments roving gangs
of children and something to do with
eggo waffles but they managed to trace
the person of interest to the local
middle school they arrived at the middle
school just in time to watch the girl
use apparent psychic abilities to fend
off government operatives before the
same monster arrived to massacre the men
as the two operatives watched from a
distance hidden just out of sight they
prepared to apprehend the monster and
administer amnestics to the children
present but before they could the girl
and the monster were gone shortly after
this incident will byers was reportedly
returned to his home but dr gears
couldn't leave hawkins just yet not with
so many new questions unanswered where
had the buyer's boy been all this time
what was the creature they had
encountered where had it come from what
had that unusually powerful girl done
with it and most importantly with more
follow in the beast's footsteps coming
to snatch more children from the streets
with authorization from the scp
foundation dr gears reached out to dr
owens at the mysterious laboratory he
offered to share the information they
had managed to gather if dr owens would
provide him with full transparency and
do the same owens was hesitant but after
being subjected to one of dr gears
trademark hour-long lectures consisting
of reasoned logical extremely dry
arguments he relented dr gears
celebrated this little triumph and dr
owens reported a persistent headache
after listening to the other man prattle
on for such a long time
dr gears and his team now had concrete
information to share with their
higher-ups at the foundation they
learned all about the gateway to another
world that the scientists had opened at
the lab the creatures that had come
through its supernatural doorway and the
connection to the psychic girl that had
disappeared at the middle school now
that an open line of communication had
been established
dr gears was working to convince owens
and the rest of the scientists at the
lab to allow him to use their portal it
was his intention to take his team of
six operatives through the gateway into
this other world there he would be able
to create a first-hand report for the
foundation allowing them to categorize
the various creatures inside and perhaps
the strange new dimension itself however
just after dr owens and his staff agreed
to allow an scp foundation expedition
into the upside down as it was
colloquially called disaster struck a
presence from the other side of the gate
used the buyer's boy to infiltrate the
laboratory dispatching a group of
juvenile creatures to attack the
scientists there dr gears was inside
when it happened looking through some of
the official reports he had been granted
access to
suddenly there were sounds of chaos from
down the hall shrieks of terror and
agony he peered through the window of
the room to see quadripedal almost
canine variations of the larger monster
bounding down the hallway leaving a
trail of blood in their wake remembering
his commitment to avoid involving
himself unless absolutely necessary dr
gears barricaded the door and hid from
the creatures as they ripped through the
rest of the lab the dog-like monsters
tore the lab staff apart and injured dr
owens in the process then in retaliation
the psychic girl closed the gate between
the worlds in doing so she removed the
threat of the monsters tearing dr gear's
limb from limb as they had so many
others but the damage was done just the
same if that wasn't bad enough a tape of
dr owen speaking candidly about the
lab's activity was leaked to the local
media and the laboratory was promptly
shut down for good with it it seemed all
the foundation's access to the anomalies
and hawkins were lost still in spite of
these new obstacles dr gears refused to
give up there were terribly strange
things afoot in hawkins and he had been
sent there to uncover them he was going
to continue to do his job until some
authority told him otherwise besides he
had gotten quite used to living
undercover in this little town he didn't
get out much but he hadn't gotten out
all that much before hawkins either it
was nice to settle into small town life
where very little ever changed until the
star court mall opened local businesses
began to close disrupting dr gears
routine and causing him a great deal of
irritation and then of course there was
the matter of the secret russian
laboratory beneath that mall which
unleashed a malevolent entity from the
upside down into the town the foundation
team watched as yet again the familiar
group of civilians neutralized the
threat and closed the gateway to the
other world several of dr gearz's
assistants suggested interrogating the
civilians or at the very least giving
them amnestics to make them forget what
they had seen dr gears ever the stickler
for the rules reminded them that they
had been given strict orders not to
interfere if the threat moved outside of
the bounds of hawkins that would be one
thing for now it seemed fairly well
contained
in fact it seemed as if all of it might
be over for good the buyer's family left
town for california and life in town
settled back into a mundane rhythm or at
least it did until the murders began
first a well-liked cheerleader found
mutilated in a trailer then an ambitious
student reporter the town flew into
chaos blaming anything they could think
of for the horrific losses dungeons and
dragons the misunderstood tabletop
role-playing game was a convenient
scapegoat but of course dr gears knew
better this was the influence of
something from the other side something
not of this plane if only he could get
back through the gate and finally take a
look for himself dr gears was not a
praying kind of man but his quiet wishes
were answered when one of his men
returned to headquarters after taking a
swim in a nearby lake he ran through the
door still sopping went sir
he panted you're gonna want to see this
please get a towel first dr gears
insisted you're dripping all over the
floor it's hardwood show some decency
after the man was sufficiently dry dr
gears brought the team to investigate
the lake there at the bottom of the
water was an ominous red glow a gate he
couldn't be sure how or why it had
opened on its own down there but an
opportunity had finally presented itself
he called his superiors at the
foundation suited up in protective gear
complete with pistols and waterproof
communication systems and dove down into
the water three officers right behind
him the other three would remain on the
other side ready to call for backup or
swiftly flee town if anything went
sideways finally dr gears would lead an
expedition into the upside down as i
swam toward the bottom of the lake into
the gate to the unknown writhing black
tendrils slithered out from the opening
snaking around the three men
accompanying him and yanking them
through dr gears was an excellent
swimmer the monotony of laps in his
local pool being one of his favorite
ways to maintain top-notch physical
shape and he sped through the water
after them when he entered the gate he
suddenly emerged into a dark facility of
the world he had just left behind he
peered through the visor of his suit
taking in his surroundings it was a cold
shadowy landscape shaped vaguely like
hawkins but alien and foreboding more of
those vine-like tentacles curled along
the ground and grey spores drifted
through the air like falling snow the
cries of strange creatures filled the
air drowned out only by the pain screams
of the three men he had followed through
the gate dr gears looked around for the
source of the sound and spotted it the
three members of personnel were
struggling to free themselves from the
grip of the ropey tendrils that had
pulled them inside and as they did
winged creatures were descending on them
from above on all sides they vaguely
resembled bats with flapping leathery
wings but their faces their mouths were
completely unlike anything dr gears had
ever seen with the exception of the
other monsters that had crossed through
the rift from this place and into his
own world these bad-like creatures were
swarming his team biting at their flesh
as the men helplessly tried to fend them
off there was only one thing left to do
dr gears drew his weapon and fired into
the sky at the teeming mass of wings and
teeth the bad things reacted and turned
their attention to him his marksmanship
did not miss however and he managed to
take out a dozen or so of the vermin
before his men could free themselves and
come to his aid two of his men at least
one unfortunately succumbed to his
wounds and would have to be left behind
it was a shame of course but he knew
what he was signing up for when he
joined the ranks of the foundation it
was then that dr gears remembered
something else he had brought with him
inspired by the victory he had witnessed
all that time ago the only thing that
had sent the monster back to hell was
fire so he strapped a foundation-issued
flamethrower to his back he drew this
secondary weapon the flamethrower and
sent a blast of flames soaring through
the air barbecuing the bats to a crisp
with the threat dispelled at least
temporarily he beckoned the men to
follow him through the unforgiving
landscape making note of everything he
saw for each and every detail that made
hawkins memorable there was an
equivalent to it here covered in those
strange spores and a layer of palpable
malice as the group made their way
through the upside down dr gears at the
front they spotted what appeared to be
the remains of the teenagers whose
deaths were being investigated by the
town they were bound up in the vines
left on display but by what or more
likely by who
dr gears could not see any other sign of
human life here as his mind began to
wander running through the possibilities
something caught his attention a long
loud clear sound like the ringing of
church bells no not quite like the chime
of a grandfather clock it rang once
twice three times a fourth he couldn't
see a clock anywhere but the sound
appeared to be coming from a massive
house up ahead nestled within the trees
the eerie red light just barely
illuminated the place's silhouette but
as gears and his remaining two
assistants approached he could see that
it was a stately home now an obvious
disrepair he had somehow missed its
earthbound equivalent and had never seen
the place before but here it was the
door standing open as if beckoning him
inside wait here keep watch he know that
to the officers behind him i'll take it
from here with the pistol in one hand
and the other poised and ready to draw
the flamethrower at a moment's notice he
stepped into the house he was right to
have his weapon drawn no sooner had he
stepped inside that the vines coiled
around his ankles one winding around his
throat and squeezing with a few quick
shots he was able to force them to
recede and continue his investigation he
climbed the creaky stairs to the attic
looking for signs of new life he briefly
thought of trying to use his
communicator to check in with the men on
the other side but when he pressed its
buttons it only emitted white noise it
was a favorite sound of his when he
vastly preferred to to the cacophony of
music but now was not the time he
switched it back off and carried on
alone then just as he crossed the
threshold into the attic he heard it
again the chime with the clock in the
corner of his eye he spotted it an
antique grandfather clock before he
could react to that though he heard a
voice behind him daddy he turned to see
a little girl staring up at him why are
you leaving us don't you love us he was
too stunned to speak the little girl's
eyes turned white her face dripping like
melting wax as she repeated why did you
leave why why why he couldn't explain it
but his heart began to pound he could
taste blood in the back of his throat
behind the little girl a figure emerged
human in shape only a twisted face and
form made of exposed muscle and more of
those awful tentacle vines approaching
him slowly it haunts you doesn't it
doctor what you did to your family
the figure asked in a menacing voice
finally dr gears found the ability to
speak again this all seems like a bit
much don't you think he didn't have much
patience for pageantry of any kind and
he certainly didn't appreciate this what
is this some sort of psionic mind prison
the entity that dr gears had no name for
but those determined kids from hawkins
knew as vecna tilted its head to the
side quizzically i can see your heart i
know the darkness within you it hissed
dr gears reached down for his
communicator giving it one more shot as
the entity approached him with slow
threatening steps as it reached its
fingers towards his face he flipped a
switch and that lovely white noise
blared to life
suddenly the little vision of the girl
was gone the clock stopped chiming vecna
was still there though glowing at dr
gears with a mixture of fury and just
plain irritation i have more important
things to attend to than you
go back to your world while you still
can with the flick of his wrist vecna
threw dr gears back down the stairs and
out the front door of the house where
his assistants were still dutifully
waiting dr gears was preparing to inform
them of his discovery when he heard
several new voices in the distance human
and familiar those same children were
back once again seemingly to save the
day as they had so many times before
ever the pragmatist dr gears brushed
himself off and headed back in the
direction he came best to stay out of
their way shortly after dr gears and his
task force withdrew from hawkins indiana
returning to their original foundation
sites they could monitor the situation
from afar and in the meantime leave
hawkins to the us government the
russians and that constantly surprising
group of brave clever civilians hell
maybe a few of them could be recruited
to join the foundation when they got a
bit older when asked to submit an
official report on his findings in
hawkins and his recommendation for how
the foundation should proceed with the
situation there dr gears simply wrote
this to be completely honest i think
those kids have got it covered now go
check out scp-096 versus siren head and
could scp-682 be contained in the back
rooms for more anomalous crossovers that
are out of this world